[Music]
atoms are simply defined as the smallest
indivisible part of any matter that
means atoms are very small in size how
can we say this if we take the same
example of a wall then all the bricks
that make up the wall are always small
compared to the complete wall right
similarly basic units that form a
particular matter are always small
compared to the complete substance not
tell me how big or small do you think a
single atom will be maybe we can take
another small entity and then compare
the atom to it can we think of an ant um
probably not okay so a scary little
grains of sugar
it means grains are smaller than ants so
maybe we can take a grain of sugar how
about a sand grain which is smaller than
the grain of sugar but we can still see
a grain of sand with our naked eyes so
can you tell me something smaller than
this yes we know that microorganisms
like bacteria are tinier than what we
can imagine because we cannot see them
with our naked eyes so is an atom as
small as a bacterium you will be amazed
to know that a single cell like a
bacterium is made up of millions of
atoms astonished right but the fact is
that the bacterium can be observed at
least using a microscope however seeing
a single atom is nearly impossible yes
the size of an active is that small so
that means there will be no units to
measure it either right no that's
incorrect in spite the fact that it's so
tiny
we still measure the size of an atom
with atomic radius the radius of an atom
is measured using units like nanometers
wait a second do we know what a
nanometer is in simple words one over 10
to the power 9 meters gives us one
nanometer so does that mean one
nanometer is 10 to the power negative
nine yes that's how small a nanometer is
and atoms are measured in nanometers so
imagine how small they will be now let's
take an example of a hydrogen atom the
atomic radius of a single isolated
hydrogen atom is around 5 times 10 to
the power negative 11
that's like 0.05 nanometers how
amazingly tiny now tell me if atoms are
so small why do we need to study them at
all
needless to say they make up the entire
globe yes everything that we see around
us is made up of atoms even our body is
made up of atoms so studying atoms in
detail becomes necessary to spite the
small size now if they are so small do
you think they will have any mass think
for a moment if we say that atoms come
together to make up matter
and if matter always has mass it means
atoms must possess at least some amount
of mass yes
although atoms are very tiny they do
have some mass but how do we calculate
the mass of a single atom is it
practically possible to do so
is there any way scale available to
weigh the mass of a single atom if not
can it be designed let's find that out
in our next video
[Music]
you